[Music]
so here the team Choice Awards how happy
are you to be here tonight well I come
every year so I'm excited to be back
it's always fun coming here and I can
see all my friends so it's really fun we
saw some of the former Dance Moms girls
here are you gonna say hi to anybody
tonight run inside yeah I'll probably
run into them and say them and say hi so
should be fun you guys all still keep in
touch yeah we do I always asked you
about your man when I see you but I saw
you just celebrated eight months how's
that it's great
I always get really like giddy about
yeah yeah I'm just happy and you're
working with SIA again she is directing
you how is that it's so fun like I can't
wait for everyone to see our upcoming
projects they're gonna be great
and Kate Hudson is involved right we
said she shaved her head for real for
the role right she's amazing yeah I mean
yeah she's incredible what have you
learned from her saliva I mean
everything she's she's becoming like a
family member to me so I love her so
much you can describe this project in
one word
well I would say more than one would be
like unlike anything you've seen before
[Music]